we appreciate uh him moving his schedule
around um
because as he said he was doing inside
as i told you
uh he said i've got to do inside and i
thought to myself what are you talking
about
are you you're working inside is that
where all the studio shows are no inside
the nfl
i got it all right so he did it
and now he's here to account for
spending
all super bowl post game nfl game day
final
caping for tom brady as if he did it
all 25 consecutive weeks beforehand
he is none other than my pro football
hall of fame friend who i love dearly
michael irvin are you there michael
i am absolutely here that's funny that's
funny
rick
and michael who's that you talking about
mike's about the blankies
yeah yeah yeah yeah it is the only thing
unfair about working out is you're gonna
work out
for a year and you can lose it in two
weeks
like wait a minute it should at least
take me six months to lose it since i
put a year in
right but it doesn't work that way it
does work that way that's just what it
is well you can get back there because
you were there before
so that i guess the symmetry so the
similar aspect of that michael would be
let's just say you have questions about
a football player
um and and spend many weeks questioning
that football
player's viability to be a champion
anymore
and then when that player becomes a
champion you act like that's the way you
handled it all season long for instance
just throwing that out there
rich rich the things i i did not
question his ability to become a
champion
i questioned only the strength of his
arm
to consistently do try to do what they
were trying to do was throw up the field
now now now and i always said
you would be still it's not about i
can't do it anymore
if i can't do it consistently all the
time like i used to do it
but then you find other ways to win
football games
now now i won three times
this year so three times you guys let me
lone wolf tom brady long wolf
tom brady three times
and and and so so i if i had been with
them all year
because it was you guys just stayed on
the other side i kept holding my arms
out saying come on
come on and everybody kept saying well
uh basically we can just wait because
patrick mahomes is about to pass tom
brady
all weekend and tampa i had to tell
everybody let's stop
let's stop doing this let's stop we're
doing this kid a disservice
we're saying we can't even enjoy his now
because we know he gonna get seven rings
as if it's that easy we're doing him a
disservice and then he goes and lose
that super bowl
you know what i mean tom said y'all stop
it
y'all stop i just i just thought that
was interesting richard i say this
what i was saying was there's no way
tampa can lose this super bowl
no way beyond calm beyond tom
because of the mark in the stain that it
will place upon their brain
that every time they walk in this
stadium they walk in this stadium
they'll have to they they'll have to
play their own game somewhere else next
year
they'll have to play their home game
somewhere else if they were to lose that
football game
that's what i was trying to impress upon
everybody that they did not get
and and as a matter of fact your flair
for the dramatic you uh
you you even had cannons fire off to
make that point uh in our pregame show
which was exciting that was great and
you you realized the moment you met the
moment as as only you can michael that
was phenomenal
we both posted it on our instagram
accounts and what have you
and and you were right about that and i
i do want to place that aside because
i don't want to get sidetracked about
where you were absolutely right
rather than you staking your claim on
our largest platform as you always do
know
what the moment is you know post super
bowl
show that's a huge platform for nfl
network where you
made it definitely made it sound like
you never had a doubt about tom brady
and that
i had to call you up because i got a ton
of text from people saying your your guy
irv is crushing it right now and i'm
like fantastic let me see what he's
saying
and then i'm like come on did
did the did the week two game day
morning reviewing that
that throw from one hash all the way to
the other sideline not happened
did the four finger moment on thursday
night football that you did the post
game show for did that not happen did
did none of those things happen michael
at all the repairs rich what about i got
on so hard with the repair
the repair the repairs
where he got batted back to him and he
threw it a second time like he's
supposed to be allowed to do that you
got out of my mouth
like that never happened i'm like wait a
second
hold on that you now get the opportunity
to act like you're the
you're the stat you're you're you're
you're caping for brady
like you're the only one and i'm like
hold on a second i have to call him and
we have to have a conversation about
this
that right right there's a lot in there
to unpack there's a lot
there's a lot of packaging because we're
talking about
multiple things under one umbrella under
the super bowl
umbrella we're talking about grady yes
but we're talking about
defense yes we're talking about manhood
men who are also rich that's what i'm
talking we're talking about manhood
it's like i've been telling people
there's a certain amount that there's a
certain thing
that i i will not put up with i will not
put up with if somebody coming
your you made it to the only super bowl
for you the only team to ever play in a
super bowl
in your home stadium and now you're
going to let somebody else come in
and win that game it's akin to
rich i'll tell you it's a candle
somebody's just coming in your house
coming sitting at your table eat your
food look like your wife's serving him
she sits down and he's holding her hand
eating your food
come on man and when you get rid of him
when you get him out of your house
i gotta get rid of the table i gotta
move with houses i can't even have this
you see what i'm saying so that's what
was on tampa's head
if they let this go on they can't come
in this stadium again
because that's all they will see is that
scene right there and that that manhood
challenge came out and that's what won
that game for
man hey hey fournette fournette the way
he was running
oh my fornette they should have had the
police outside
waiting for nick that was blunt force
trauma he was delivering
those dudes blunt force trauma we should
have put us
it was it was insane washington that
that was man who was stuff
that i was talking about and that day
he's played yesterday
michael irvin here on the rich eisen
show and devon white had that manhood
mentality right there and again so i've
been
you know busting your stones since you
called in about
being able to say that you could cape
for brady
like you did for 25 straight weeks and
you didn't but
you were spot on michael uh with
the prior uh to the game conversation
that we had on game day morning where we
all were like well home field advantage
it's not like the crowd's gonna be
that noisy on behalf of the box well
it's not like the chiefs
had to stay on the road all week like a
normal super bowl they were home and
so what sort of mentality what sort of
home field advantage they really can
have it's just like a business trip for
the chiefs they fly out on saturday they
play games sunday they go home monday
and then have a parade on tuesday
and you were like no no no no no like
this is somebody's home
turf and and you tech i think you texted
the the entire chain when when devin
white picked one off and you read his
lips saying not in our house like you
were you were
you were just i don't know how i mean
that was it he was leading that charge
in that like
because like like weeks you know week
two
2021 week three 2022
week 9 2023 at raymond james stadium
they'd be looking at the the end zone
where mahomes was holding up the trophy
and picking confetti out of their hair
like they can't have that
you can't have that it rich you saw all
the other things that you know okay
we're just shooting inside nfl
so i get all of the video get to see
even highlights that
no other shows get you know what i mean
right the only show for those shows
but you can see you can see all of it
to holding up the two fingers that
antoine went for i was with anton
whitfield junior
and his dad after the super bowl i was
celebrating with them
you know but holding up the two fingers
antifa
uh uh devin white over on the phone
marching hey they sent help
send help you see all of that with that
what went down in week 12
and the way it went down that that that
played all the role and they were
feeding it all back it was so great to
watch
i mean i just i love football and i love
the technical side of football
but i love man i love man more and to
see
the depths that men can pull out
though please i don't want anybody
texting me uh saying
michael's on i'm when i say man i'm
speaking in a biblical sense man is man
and one man
man as a male woman that's a man with
the womb god gave up
how babies okay man woman i'm talking
man in that base so i'm talking all
people
everybody just the depths that they can
go to to bring the best
out of them and what makes them go to
those depths
that's what i love watching when i see
this game and i saw it in that super
bowl that's what made it such a great
game
well it's one thing you do love more
than all of that michael and that's
being right
that's being right
i was just sitting there shaking my head
watching you on game day final i'm like
this is a guy
that is so excited about being right
he's so excited that he got his lone
wolf right
and that he's sitting there talking
about that they weren't gonna allow
anything like this to happen in their
house right i mean you
you nailed that one directly on the head
and how about aryans coming on
afterwards and saying
i want to speak to michael because he's
the only one on that damn set that
picked us
i
that was that was that was straight by
coach too that gave me straight cred
that straight cred right
family right now all right
i went out and celebrated with the
buccaneers family they gave me straight
craze
over there with them
all season long your pre-season pic they
were my pre-season pick
and then i backed off and now they were
my pre-season pick
and then i backed off them and now here
you are on super sunday night partying
like you're a glazer like you own a team
i would i was i was in the middle of
ebook
city where everybody got you know and
they were crazy and i was
i was really preaching like camp they i
was like oh my god this is insane man
i had to calm down and say calm down you
actually like you just won the super
bowl
i can't just celebrate it was so much
fun man oh my god
just to see it man i was happy for him i
was happy for that i really was it was a
great suit
you're happy for yourself too my gosh
all right yeah yeah yeah
but to that what's the lesson in that
rich is timing is everything
it's great to be right but it's great to
be right at the right time
yeah what timing is that's what that
says this is just him doing the first
down signal
after getting like one catch on third
and two that's what i'm looking at
that's
this is what it is right now this is
what's happening
this is what's happening because i chose
the bucks i'm looking at everybody in
the studio right now
i chose the bucks first i chose them i
chose them
but i chose them back tuesday after
labor day is when i chose
yes and then they go seven and five
okay it's thanksgiving weekend bail and
and right before they go seven and five
right before that chiefs game
i bailed i bailed i'm like i don't think
so
and then i bailed again and now i see
him just
one like he's uh i can't handle it it's
very difficult
this is like lock of the week like i
don't want to do lock of the week
anymore
and i don't want to do this anymore you
hate luck of the week despise luck of
the week
like irv like what's a lock that tom
brady's great i mean is
oh okay so before i let you go on inside
as you referred to
what did you see what what what piece of
footage have you seen yet that the rest
of us haven't seen that that that might
have gleaned
gave you anything uh that in in the the
show you just recorded that we'll see on
showtime
that's a good question rich that's a
good question and
and and you guys see it and you see it
tonight you'll see like whatever the
footage everybody wants to hear
they'll play some of that footage also
be super upbeat about that battle
between tom brady and tyrone matthew and
all of those things
some of that will be played absolutely
i'm gonna tell you this yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna say this
i i didn't like the tyron matthews put
that out like that
the way he put it out honestly because
i i thought come on now you know
it makes it sound as if it makes people
want to know what he said we're curious
as if he said the n word and he did not
tom did not so you know i i don't even
like that even
looming over this situation so that's
why
i think we should clean that up
somewhere somehow
that's what i'm saying so you didn't say
you didn't say that so did we he
do we hear the word or that he said to
tyron tonight
i i i can't even talk about that they
really thought
well i really can't you just gotta see
what's okay in the night but but
but i'm just because they they told us
you know let it play
okay we will let it play then irv um
thanks
thanks for playing here uh michael i
posted to
understand what i'm saying i don't know
and and unfortunately because tyron's
tyranny because tyron is to be able to
tyron is a champion
and an alpha male in his own right and
it was just two guys that were you know
barking at each other
and there's good you know good you're
right that's all it is and it's the
first time the time i mean not to make
any excuses here but
his first time tyron's lost the super
bowl it's a feeling that i'm sure
is very empty for him and but you're
right and but i guess brady called and
apologized to
whatever happened and these are two guys
that are you know um
were i i you know we're definitely i
i mean it's tough to call anybody a
period of brady's when we're talking
about the number that he has but we're
talking about two guys who are competing
competitors
and and heater moment will hit and which
is why i guess you you you keep it quiet
uh travel safe right on a serious note
on one last year's note and here let me
say this on both sides it's important
that we get it out like you're okay he
didn't city and work
that day because i don't think that's
fair and just for tom
and when we leave it lingering like that
some people think or may say
i mean you know i mean have thoughts and
it wasn't that but also on our side as
an african-american side because i don't
want people to think
okay are they just saying it again or
implant applying it again
so so it's like it's crying woof and
then when it really happens nobody
listens
you see what i'm saying so i want to
squash all of that this was just two
guys
competing that was that's what that is
it's just two guys competing
irv love you you have a safe flight home
um
and i'll have you back on uh later on
maybe this month when maybe the deshawn
watson stuff heats up or when when
things are happening and
and we'll stay in touch and you can keep
uh rooting your waving your pom-poms for
tom
and um it'll be great it'll be great
yeah i'm officially
our buccaneer
i love you that's michael irvin
everybody